myers
sem falar que o time já marina cirurgias
mais obrigada obrigada por me aceitarem
é porque eu sei que não é fácil falar do
técnico com bola e como você está muito
bem e aparentemente estes dois conceitos
são impossíveis kenko e humor
eu chamaria ele tem 24 anos e antes de
começar aqui só dizer que está tudo bem
o som está ok este ruído que vocês ouvem
quando eu falo é só me pronuncio padrão
está tatuado operacional de facto e os o
falcão que o corpo e ficar claro eu não
teria nunca o time da história aqui
falar dos outros é e há quem diga até
que eu só falo que o porto não recanto é
vê lá eu tenho esse hábito estúpido
estado vive tão fácil fazer coisas é e
eu quando começa a falar isso ficou
modificadas assim com você estamos com a
idéia é que de facto quando o doente
uma foi amy meio a arma eu pensei para
lá se o brincar comigo se eu já
comuniquei eca eu não vou ter ocorrido
na escola eu estou a sua via tentar pôr
baixo eu já fiz isso eu já avisei que
comigo por isso nada me afeta equipas
estão à nossa volta inclusive planos
particulares familiares era mais fácil
ter um doente posto seu longo deste
tempo
nestes últimos dois anos e meio tempo
que cada ano de vida é falar de cancro
como sai por criar um projeto em comum
onde escreve um blog com textos
humorísticos onde falava neste mundo
cantando o amor centavos e pan e
esperando claro o feedback dos doentes
oncológicos claro que se achassem que
estava ganhando porque ele não fazia
sentido eu pagávamos como o fato de
identificação é ficar continue mais
tarde que chegar a mais gente e funda
juntamente com o normal e sony cômico
simão a associação quer que o cômodo
para poder fazer atividades com os
dentes
hoje onde o mote é ser feliz no caos e
finalmente lancei o livro tem como
objetivo as pessoas através destas
clínicas humorística é igual a vocês
pensam que ela já não tem a
originalidade uma visita não dizer que
quem como eu quero colocar em comum nos
factos o que como tem sido minha vida é
igual então que contextualizados em que
vim com que eu tenho feito hoje hoje
quero dar o meu testemunho enquanto
antológica hoje então pode ficar mas
quero fazer uma coisa diferença hoje é
um dia especial porque quer falar também
do meu papel enquanto cuida porque faz
que eu estou vivendo explica que este
projeto não fazia ideia que se ia
acontecer mas talvez por fazer isto com
tanto amor é acontecer aconteceu longe e
que vai por 111 apaixonar por um careca
paula então não te ser feliz no caos
como eu quer que o que eu quero é do meu
parceiro e agora vocês perguntam marinho
é possível ser feliz no cairo por favor
marina é possível ser feliz do que é e
bolatti que eu sei que isto vai levar a
minha relação e penso pela tela ter
ficar em que eu estava no segundo tempo
como é que é possível eu acho estranho
mas os juros que eu tenho uma relação
super saudável e sei que as pessoas é às
vezes quase kika que pensam que é um
drama porque eu quando conheci a minha
carga é quando começamos a namorar
descobrimos o segundo e claro que nunca
é fácil mas garante não ser o namoro
super emocionante e cheio de novidades
freskinhas do bié vai hoje ser uma coisa
nova que eu quero ir vivendo é nos
carros entre este curso não fosse um
morro estava nos chats aaven envolve
mais quebrada mas mais nervosa por fato
pra mim é muito muito mais difícil falar
do campo e do tipo feito mais em
senadores
estou só piada seja uma pessoa que me
choca é muito mais difícil falar do
campo na segunda pessoa sentindo muito
mais incompetente é mais doloroso é e
claro também tite onip as bolas vida
tanto tempo tanto quem parece que vive
está é duvidar da minha capacidade será
original porque o juiz tinha capacidade
para suprir outras noites
não sei eu acho eu acho sinceramente não
sei por que nunca perdeu uma perna
eu acho tempo foi do evento o filme está
sendo menos faca domingos faz é ver
porque ele na televisão também pela
estendida não examino conhecido elogia
não tem nenhuma polícia não era de
cancelar a nós e com rocha o chocolate
não que também não viu muitas foi e não
quem canta é tão bom porque a outra
outra curiosidade convosco
este mês foi fazer uma consulta de
rotina porque será
apesar de ver que sou hipocondríaco é
com esta brincadeira eu acho que tudo
pode acontecer afirma o consultor tina e
nuno pinto do todo ver com aquela
conversa de mary em tempo de conversar a
mesma coisa quando uma mulher chega à
casa de lixo é bom temos que conversar
nós tivemos que vem merda né
nem temos como temos que conversar e
etanol e que até fazer uma biópsia
suspeita de melanoma em um mototáxi
rocinha doutor que o plano já tem três
quer que em casa não posso dar nenhum
graças a deus pessoal susto estou a ir
menos vezes foi só para evitar imaginem
como é que uma pessoa não dá pra ficar
um pouquinho porque eu não posso no
banana mais ç ã rã ser doente oncológico
tem muito que se lhe diga não é nada
fácil puc nossa dimensão ecológica e
imunidade passa por isso é
constantemente também é avisado do que
como eu não foi justamente tips
quimioterapia não que o campeão logo não
ter feito o teste tem quer que o faz ser
fãs mas eu não vou ser feliz
eu era um ímã para pessoas que não vão
falar de doenças
toda a gente sabe que é o dom a quem tem
o dom da doença
né então se vinha doente oncológico
penso que nós só falamos de campo e no
caso do a
vai vir treinar aqui e ali como
temporário 19 os mesmos parto bom e acho
que nós só vamos falar de doenças é
então quando nos veem aquelas pessoas
que jogam doença estão sempre numérica é
uma instituição quando e como ele chama
bom peixe e vêm ter connosco e toca aqui
é futebol e na doença não é filha começa
sempre assim
a aip ea emi no entanto têxtil e meu
show do álbum no joelho passar o papel
numa chuva de papel uma vez que nenhum
pé e no pé tem 11 indicam que a vaga
está mesmo em pequenas bonita
bom isso é mais ou menos isso nós
perguntamos então possuir las à noite
que traz alegria o médico que o caso é
grave é que a pessoa tem uma doença
transpira e fica nervosa porque sabe
tudo a doença que tem não vai competir
comigo nem com quem compete com o cân
então vai usar esta expressão muito
conhecida que é e paga nem fácil falar e
painel faz falar significa eu tenho que
emagrecer muito grave da nova gripe no
rio e além do ímã para pessoas que é
dolo falar de doenças somos também um
ímã para o malte presente época como
você achava tudo então é lógico é muito
presente eu recebi porque eu sou eu ela
o casal na minha comida por isso domingo
nós enviamos as portas da minha casa
literalmente para receber toda sofre não
estava lá eu sentei me no sul nos fatos
são paulo papa é receber os presentes e
até parece piada mas o problema é que o
sofre dois tipos de 200
esta é fácil você já sabe quais é que já
existe não escolhe
de flanela era sinto flanela quiser só a
chuva era tudo foi nela e os 13 anos lá
estava eu a respeito dos 20 já
assistiram aos filmes distintos mas toda
a gente aqui ficha eu tinha a minha ea
cp fisco leva bela da tarde maçã e optou
pelo fim da fila e passou a se fechar
aliança também lembra o mesmo precisava
esposa meu quintal e tutti gatinha de
tarde comecei o que acontece mas sem
tarde e já ficar nós vamos sentar com
eles assim e filho não sabe crítico
misto para as pessoas comuns dimensão
lógico que nunca podem comer nada se
fosse um carro vem de uma convincente
lado dose por dia mas está começando e
que acontece mas há nessas reuniões
familiares lá das oferendas deixadas
mensagens que acontece aí as pessoas têm
tirado do pan não está só falar porque
não é de fazer em alguma coisa em
conjunto
então que as famílias fazem filmes
inovação em suas palavras em pessoas
saudáveis porque as famílias nunca sabem
que é um dever não é um cão fundação e
não por perdigão já o menino outra moto
mas só então tem que chegar a um
consenso rapidamente o que se vê é que
as famílias vêem conjunto o filme todos
gostam que é unânime porque vou curtir a
minha família toda a gente gosta de
tatuagens toda a gente não tem 27
sim toda a gente falou é que não há quem
não funcionam mais pessoas todos os
gostos
ah eu moro no final gostosas a ficar nem
toda a gente a chorar naturalmente o
release do selecionado nacional da
família eu estacionar se o doente
oncológico chora
alguém já que ele está a chapa tem quem
como podem ver é não fazer como o
benefício nós somos devemos equipe
quando vocês vão se habituando também os
losers que eu sei que também é difícil e
esse tipo de humor mas como disse vou
voltar diz não fosse um ovo estávamos no
chat
r bom você estivesse que o que é que o
paulo e eu tenho que falar que é bem
mais atenção do que eu porque é que ele
é quem inspira e claro nós temos regras
a nossa relação funcionar isso tudo
acontece uma regra foi o que impulsionou
falou em xavi e epa não se pode usar o
pai teve pop coisas não só tem 2 que só
que é bom eu estava sempre me lê vestito
aniversários nfa de épocas festivas aí
pronto e permitimos e olha que eu sou
muito rigorosa é ter um momento de
pressão dos choramos e olha meu deus a
minha vida que tristeza de duas em duas
semanas de 20 minutos apenas
depois é amigo vai para conviver que não
tocará isto e isto é muito importante
essas regras para nós nos sentimos
felizes porque ela está se não fossemos
a um dos chats e também temos algumas
limitações físicas e eu eu antigo tem
uma prótese no joelho está mais limitado
fisicamente se não podemos fazer
atividade física sem grandes caminhadas
é enfim
e como eu disse eu sou coluna pois fomos
feitos um para o outro
ninguém sente eu não podia andar eu
também não tinha tem nada com isso e eu
já disse que me libera tivesse mais
novos de nava porque essas coisas vão se
adaptando a um porquê porque não fosse
um mundo estavam fechados e nossa é essa
é a minha história e como há tantas jan
de como as tantas histórias tecla e eu
tenho que dizer isso eu não eu não falo
assim não estou aqui só para defender a
e só para para para dizer que uma
loucura e que as pessoas não morrem qat
direção a gente sabe isso e aquilo que o
tento é fazer nas minhas palestras na
minha posição e nem que o gol por 20 é
que é importante valorizar também partiu
é aquela história tem que valer alguma
coisa que garantimos que o lula falando
estas pessoas também já faleceram
van gaal viu eu quando fiz uma palestra
que comemorar muito tempo atrás recebi
uma mensagem de uma mãe que tinha
perdido a filha com o site what's up e
há pouco tempo a portuguesa muito
obrigada por quanto por esta manhã eu
lembrei da minha vânia quando elas
novamente força quando ela sorria e não
não vi aquelas imagens tão pesadas com
duras é e eu pensei o que é possível
fazer isto porque o momento também é que
surge por um familiar seu serviço em
guardas ofendido de alguma forma mas
perante o fisco também podem ajudar
estas pessoas e sem dúvida espanha muito
importantes porque não é só para quem
está vendo é que eu também aprendi muito
nesta caminhada do cheque como é é
chover o conceito tempo sobretudo é que
colocar a capa é claro que não não sinto
nem consegui ainda não se considera que
nós que seja tão pouco ainda ontem os
apaixonados e não começamos a viver a
vida não não vou sequer pensaram que nós
tempo poderá ser culto ou não é na
verdade é que o tempo é relativo à
jornada que não é singular não é para
ficar e vai morrer ele é macho podemos
ter uma vida longa ou não a amiga duas
fazemos é respeitar esse tempo e viu o
máximo
não há cá tempo mesmo lados nem
primeiros vídeos vivemos tudo muito
velha e tomar assim e quando falamos
muito de moto não seguindo preocupação é
fácil não se pôde ver que eu fique bem
isso tudo não perca esta vontade de
fazer outras coisas enquanto é isso é
muito importante em cada moto
nós fizemos a palavra moto ainda como se
for só conhecer aquelas pessoas não é
uma realidade lamento dizer sim sim mas
vamos todos morrer se não é parece que é
uma coisa tão distantes e quando nós
vivemos este caso de quem onde e como
dizia o poema
os dias com moto não temos que ter
atenção mas ela está ali todos são bons
dias para morrer
é esta realidade torna-se mais palpável
no flamengo porque não dizer que todos é
que temos um carinho é mensagem que
quero transmitir hoje é sejam pois
independentemente todos contest é
possível ser um vetor código pois é
possível ter um namoro com estas
limitações onde onde todos os dias
existem novas proporções mas também
novas lutas e novas novas possibilidades
é que nós mesmos lógicos o bicheiro vale
de 20 poços que vamos fazer um bom jogo
estamos a brincar que temos do jacaré
que estava muito bem que conhecia essa é
o projeto que comova seu facebook a
associação quer como também
isso tudo é que o q1 eu queria terminar
com uma reflexão e não acredito que não
haja que alguém que não esteja
minimamente sensibilizar toca que eu
podia dizer que querem estudar a gente
conheça alguém que teve com a ex-mulher
com quem quer que o boato a gente está
familiarizado com esta questão é uma
realidade de todos nós
é por isso que tentarem ter aula como
máxima positividade possível é não
tentar fazer estudando é melhor do que é
um drama nós tivemos mas podemos viver
de uma forma feliz e ponto de compensar
a parte mais neste ano que o exemplo tem
de ser também uma bela é valorizar é um
exposição isso risos vocês foram uma
platéia ok meu muito obrigada e até a
próxima